first question i have for you is one
just what's your general take so far on
bitcoin uh futures etf it just literally
got approved officially uh so it's gonna
start trading at the beginning of next
week what's your uh what's your feeling
on this
yeah i mean it's super bullish in my
opinion um i mean i would i would
preface it with saying i'm i would never
buy the product um
but i think it's it's really bullish in
the sense that it unlocks a lot of uh
you know potential inflows from like you
know sort of the trap boomer capital
that that's out there um you know
there's just there's just so much you
know money in a zero yield negative
yield world uh real yield so so the
futures etf even though it's not spot
even though it's you know on the cme um
it's going to unlock a lot of capital in
the kind of the second order effects of
that are really bullish in my opinion
got it and then in terms of uh when you
start to actually look at the um uh
bitcoin futures etf i'm assuming you
think the spot etf would be better
yeah um and i think one of the like kind
of bullish things about it is that i
think the spot etf is coming and this is
just like kind of the first first step
or the first domino um gensler and scc
has a lot of i mean there's a lot of
noise out there in the crypto markets in
general and i think they want to kind of
set a precedent here um with what's with
what's you know okay what's not um the
futures the cme is is very regulated
exchange and i you know some people say
it's market leading i don't believe that
at all um in the sense that it's paper
traded it's you know it's the legacy
hours of of trading but at the same time
um you know there is billions of dollars
of capital of open interest on this so
in the bitcoin futures contract so in
that sense um it's really good but yeah
physically settled or you know
physically settled bitcoin etf would be
far superior in my opinion got it and
we've got a couple of charts here from
you the first is looking at let's start
looking at the actual futures uh
interest itself we were talking to will
about some uh stuff but you've got a
couple of different ways to look at this
so bitcoin futures aggregated open
interest what exactly does that mean and
what are you seeing here
yeah so this is the total uh open
interest on the bitcoins uh futures cmu
like lscme exchange so it's at all-time
highs basically what it means is just
that the total amount of like
directional betting uh on the cme has
hit all-time highs so this for me when i
was i was looking at these charts last
week um the basis which kind of blew out
which we'll go over in a few minutes um
that was kind of one of the leading
indicators that hey like something's
happening under the surface here um and
maybe maybe you know smart money or some
insider trading was front running this
move i don't know if you know that's
insider so much as just kind of uh you
know front running the news but yeah
open interest at all time highs in the
cme um that just kind of shows you that
there's a lot of demand here and i think
people are trying to front run like the
coming etf demand for for the futures
got it and so when you actually go ahead
and you look at the second chart that
you have here uh you've got this
annualized rolling one-month basis what
is this
yeah so basically what this means is
like so for any commodity when you hear
like a futures what that means is that
you know it's it's easier to think of it
not maybe in bitcoin but like say oil or
any traditional commodity right um
there's a there's a futures market so
you can buy the commodity today but also
you can um you can buy the commodity in
february of 2023 and there's a market
for that and there's a you know a price
for that so with bitcoin it's the same
thing there's there's a futures price
and so what this basis is is essentially
it's the difference between the spot
price today uh and the futures price
tomorrow but or next month or next year
but it's annualized so when the basis
says 20 uh you know annualized that
means that if you if you sell the
futures contract and buy spot uh on an
annualized basis you can get 20 yields
which is which is really significant in
a again like a zero zero interest rate
environment um that's one of the most
bullish things about this is that you
know you're gonna have a way um you know
especially if there's some somewhat of a
better spot vehicle that comes to market
for traders for wall street for legacy
capital to come in and capture 20 yields
uh when they can't get you know when you
when bond yields are are negative in
real terms you're buying a junk bond at
five percent with inflation at six right
like it that doesn't make sense so you
know a lot of people even if they're
agnostic to crypto to bitcoin they don't
care
20 yields make you make you wake up